[Musique]
venus des départements du centre de la
france ce qu'on appelle par extension
les auvergnats prétendre volontiers
avoir conquis paris ils possèdent leur
journal leur foyer d'accueil et leur
paroisse chaque rue de paris à son bunia
car c'est bien souvent en poussant une
charrette à bras qu'ils font
connaissance avec la capitale leurs
vertus font le reste est monsieur de la
malène qui les connaît bien puisqu'il
est aveyronnais nous a tracé le portrait
de ses compatriotes une il ya deux
professions dans lesquels on rencontre
énormément d'aveyronnais ce sont la
brasserie les cafés et les bureaux de
tabac
mais j'ai commencé a débuté dans le
charbon nominés dit pape et patron à
l'époque j'avais j'étais garçon quand
j'ai débuté dans le charbon beau remuer
comme ont commis là que j ai maintenant
et maintenant je suis patron et pourquoi
elles m'ont choisie et les bois et
charbon
parce que quand j'ai débuté à paris café
charbon qu'on appelle
le bistrot est le charbonnier qui est
une chose qui était qui et et
charbonnières
c'était facile pour vous moniotte alors
j'ai continué ensuite passer elle même
c'est à dire de patrons et des petit à
petit j'ai commencé à grandir quoi enfin
comment dire faire le petit magro et
filles et aujourd'hui je suis patron
maintenant il ya un beau mâle où elles
font tellement groupe va dire est
tellement grand homme a faim on arriva à
commencer quoi
à quelle qualité attribué cette réussite
beaucoup de sérieux
beaucoup d'esprit d'initiative un grand
sens de l'économie et une fidélité aux
vertus traditionnelles du terroir auquel
nous tenons par dessus tout il reste
très près les uns des autres
le plus possible nous le nous le faisons
à la fois dans l'intérêt de notre petite
patrie est aussi dans notre note dans
notre intérêt propre
nous savons que c'est parce que nous
sommes restés devrait aveyronnais que
beaucoup d'entre nous ont réussi
convenablement dans la vie et nous
tenons à poursuivre ce chemin et nous le
faisons aussi parce que comme nous
devons beaucoup à notre pays nous
pensons qu'il faut que nous lui rendions
tout ce qui nous a donné et c'est un des
buts de ne rencontrer de nos amicales
la mlv la bible
[Musique]
oh
m
[Musique]
le folklore auvergnat reste très vivace
il a ses fidèles supporters et c'est au
son d'une bourg et endiablé que nous
quitterons ces joyeux auvergnats qui
sont tous bien entendu d'excellents
parisien
[Musique]